i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
hace muchos años iba yo en carro con mi
bebé acabábamos de dejar a sus hermanos
en el jardín infantil pasamos por un
paradero de buses y vi un letrero
espectacular con una modelo y decía deja
que esta cerveza hable por ti miré por
el retrovisor miré a mi bebita que
balbuceaba movía sus manos y trataba de
repetir todas las palabras que oía día a
día y entonces yo pensé como es posible
que haya una empresa o que haya una
compañía que quiera callar a las mujeres
yo quisiera que mi hija creciera en una
sociedad de mujeres calladas fue
entonces como llegué a mi casa escribí
un texto muy breve una columna muy
cortita y llamé a un periódico local era
un periódico pequeño de circulación
regional
el editor ya me conocía me dijo que sí
que me publicaba el texto yo había sido
reportera ocho años en ese periódico
este periódico pequeño pertenecía a un
periódico mucho más grande
cuando salió esa columna a los 8 días me
llamaron del periódico más grande que
era el periódico más importante de la
región donde yo vivo en medellín y
además un periódico de corte conservador
le dijeron que se quería ser columnista
de ellos todas las semanas y empecé a
escribir una vez comencé a publicar las
columnas me di cuenta varón que en el
pasado una mujer había sido censurada
por escribir sobre temas tan
controversiales en sociedades
conservadoras como el aborto entonces yo
me preguntaba por qué tener un espacio
si ese espacio va a tener limitaciones
decidí hablar con un veterano columnista
amigo mío y le pregunté pues le pedí un
consejo y él me dijo mira cuando estás
tratando de encontrar tu voz tú lo que
debes hacer es abrirte camino poco a
poco
los que te van a decir cuando ya has
encontrado esa voz son los lectores
cuando los lectores se autoricen cuando
los lectores ya reconozcan esa voz ahí
si habla fuerte escribe duro corta la
maleza y échate a andar y así lo hice
cuando estaba en la universidad un
profesor me dijo que con esta voz tan
frágil nunca podría trabajar en radio
porque el registro era muy débil sin
embargo un poco después empecé a
trabajar en una emisora cultural donde
parecía que no había problema con mi voz
pero luego me llamaron de una emisora
comercial una emisora de grandes
audiencias concentrada en debates
los primeros años cada vez que salía al
aire todo el tiempo el productor me
decía anna más fuerte
anna habla duro anna no permitas que
nadie te grite mientras estás al aire
responde con vehemencia
lo importante no es el tono de la voz o
el volumen de la voz
lo importante es honrar la historia el
origen y el significado de las palabras
y es que no es realmente importante si
una mujer habla duro o habla abajo lo
importante es que sea genuinamente lo
que ella quiere decir y que tengan un
apego que tengan honra a las palabras a
lo que es el altar en que debe estar el
lenguaje
según la firma colombiana cifras y
conceptos el 21 por ciento de los
columnistas que escriben en colombia
somos mujeres el 33 por ciento de las
columnas que circulan en redes sociales
corresponden a organizaciones sociales
el 25 por ciento en medios de
comunicación el 18 por ciento a mujeres
académicas y el 16 por ciento a mujeres
que trabajan en política preocupa mucho
las cifras tan bajas de académicas y
políticas que participan en este tipo de
columnas porque porque las políticas
pues las mujeres que trabajan en
políticas son las que toman grandes
decisiones y las académicas son las que
estudian y analizan problemas de la
sociedad en profundidad
en la adolescencia leí un libro que se
llama una habitación propia de virginia
bus
a través de ese texto con sólo 16 años
escuché el nombre o supe del nombre de
una escritora llamada afro ven que en el
siglo 17 fue capaz de escribir de vivir
a través de la escritura
me parecía muy extraño que cuatro siglos
después todavía la gente me preguntara
para cómo te vas a atrever a escribir a
vivir y escribir uno no no puede no
puede vivir de escribir es imposible y
de la escritura pero fue así como traté
de hacerlo como sigo tratando de hacerlo
encuentro que en la escritura en las
palabras no solamente cuando hablo sino
cuando escribo cuando leo o cuando
escucho a los demás lo que estoy
haciendo es venciendo ese miedo no
solamente el mío a expresarme sino el
miedo a crear ya que vean lo que se
puede producir a través de las palabras
lo que quiere decir virginia wolf con
ese con esa habitación propia con la
figura de la habitación propia es el
lugar simbólico que son las palabras y
es el lugar simbólico es desde donde
podemos conjurar los miedos no solamente
los propios sino los de otras mujeres
a través de las palabras construimos y
destruimos mundos
cuando las sociedades tratan de limitar
las palabras de las mujeres lo que hacen
es buscar acortar esos mundos ponerles
límites más estrechos como lo hacen por
ejemplo a las mujeres que son líderes
les dicen mandonas o desde niñas nos
tratan de aplacar con frases famosas
como calladita se ve más bonita y lo que
quiero decirles hoy no es que no tengan
miedo lo que les quiero decir es que
hablen y escriban a pesar del miedo
según la federación internacional de
periodismo el 48% de las periodistas
consultadas alguna vez en su vida
sintieron violencia de género sobre
ellas el 63 por ciento dijeron haber
recibido maltrato verbal el 41 por
ciento de algún tipo de violencia
económica el 11 por ciento violencia
física y el 44 por ciento dijo haber
sido víctima de ciberacoso pero quienes
son los que hacen quienes son los
autores de ese tipo de violencias
el 45 por ciento de las oportunidades es
un extraño quién puede ser un extraño
puede ser un político o alguna fuente
una persona entrevistada alguien con
quien se relaciona en el diario
ejercicio de la profesión el 38 por
ciento de ese acoso o ese maltrato viene
de su jefe o supervisor y el 17 por
ciento por parte de algún colega aquí es
muy importante que tengamos en cuenta el
subregistro quiere decir que no todo el
mundo denuncia porque le da miedo
básicamente dos cosas primero le tiene
miedo a la ineficiencia de las
autoridades y segundo a los prejuicios
que puede haber sobre las mujeres por el
hecho de denunciar
el filósofo austriaco ludwig einstein
dijo una frase muy poderosa los límites
de mis palabras son los límites de mi
mundo
a través de la escritura y a través de
los micrófonos de la radio no solamente
he tratado de expandir los límites de mi
mundo he tratado de buscar expandir los
límites de los mundos de otras mujeres
lo que parecía que era una desventaja
una mujer de pensamiento liberal
escribiendo en un medio conservador
resultó ser paradójicamente la gran la
gran ventaja o pues lo que más favoreció
el poder de mi voz precisamente porque
ahí está la diferencia
el novelista quemara de rosa diría
narrar es resistir
y en este momento pienso que aquella
mujer que hace tantos años fue censurada
por escribir sobre el aborto ella fue la
que abrió las puertas para que mujeres
como yo y todas las mujeres que vienen
después hablemos escribamos pensemos y
creemos con más libertad
en este momento quiero leerles un pedazo
del libro que les mencioné hace un
momento de virginia wood
las obras maestras no son logros
aislados y solitarios son el resultado
de muchos años de trabajo en común del
pensamiento colectivo de muchas personas
de tal suerte que tras esta voz
individual se encuentra la experiencia
de la masa
la libertad de las mujeres es una obra
maestra que ha sido conquistada por el
poder de muchas voces durante muchos
años lo que hablo lo que escribo lo que
leo y lo que escucho es lo que trato de
poner en todos los trabajos míos en los
medios de comunicación y que básicamente
tratan de ser la representación del eco
de otras mujeres tener una columna en un
periódico o tener ese micrófono de una
emisora radial que puede expandir mi voz
por el espectro sonoro lo que hace no es
solamente por mí sino por otras mujeres
que también quieren hablar
y esa voz sirve no solamente para
expresar ideas sino para conjurar los
miedos
y es que a mí también me da miedo el
miedo está ahí pero me lo aguanto
[Música]